um well you mentioned you moved a lot
because of your dad's job so you did
learn a lot of languages right because
of that
how many like what languages i i speak i
speak german
english french italian and spanish
what yeah i mean a few of those are
latin latin-based so i get that a little
bit but german is not
no it's not actually that was my first
that was my second language that was the
first language that i learned
after i learned spanish
it seems like it would have been hard
just with friends like growing up but
what also like a cool benefit to like
just culturally speaking to experience
all of that
yeah it is it is incredible because it
makes and also i learned a lot of them
at a ver
at a very early age so it's where your
way your brain is so
plastic you know it is so uh flexible
like a sponge
exactly and um and and and it was
incredible also
you get i mean there's no there's no
representation or expression of a
culture that is more dynamic than the
language i mean we
yeah we live we speak how we live you
know so it's a
great way to get to know other cultures
so it's it's got to be cool too when
you're promoting movies and like you're
going
not now maybe but before when you're
going around the world to like promote
movies you're like just speaking in
their native tongue
yeah i tried to do that a brain movie
like dream that i've had that does not
come to fruition
but it's really cool to be able to do
and they probably love that that you
embrace their culture
yeah yeah i try to do that and um and
again i mean i love to talk
i'm an aries so you know
oh yeah yeah my rising i can't that's
why you know i was i was naughty and
active but also
good you know so i act the taurus and i
have the yeah okay i am surrounded by
aries
gemini and scorpio that's all that
surrounds me it's weird um
is it true though it's easy to learn bad
words first
for some reason i mean i was a cocktail
waitress so i know like all the guys
that used to work with me that spoke
spanish
you know i would learn all the ones i
can't say on this i mean for some reason
that's and and i think that everyone can
vouch for this for some reason
that's the first thing that people they
want to come and teach you
that tells you a lot about humanity yeah
it's very it's very weird i mean
and also they come up and and and when i
was a teenager and it was
and it was traveling and also as a kid
they come up with
also very silly yeah ways of teaching
you
bad words it's like silly compositions
of of words it doesn't even sound right
yeah that they're not a thing then
you're an adult and you know that you
were
playing with bad words that actually are
not a thing i remember i was just
telling
um cesar your your producer and and my
groomer he's german
and i remember when i when i when i when
i arrived to austria that's where i
learned um germa in austria so
i have i have an accent uh
and i remember i remember that that this
kid taught me this
expression you know it was i mean you
will blip it
it's like knee and that's like
in the knee that's not even why the knee
why to yours i mean there's like
anatomically that doesn't work i'm
getting
in the knee yeah and the knee and that
right i mean it doesn't make any sense i
think that kid was playing a joke on you
yeah he was playing a joke on me and it
stayed with me but that's not a thing so
that was my experience i'm just going to
learn that so i can yell at an airport
exactly
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever